he is the new head coach at Ohio State
of their illustrious football program he
is none other than Ryan de here on the
Rich Eisen show how are you coach great
Rick how are you I'm doing better for
talking to you that's not snow dude I'm
not joking I'm serious I wanted to meet
you and see why I already saw what's in
store thankfully yeah well thank you
yeah no we're uh decided to get going we
got a practice today in the mock game
tomorrow and then we kick it off
nine days so we're fired up over here
well obviously you did have some time
last year while Urban Meyer was on
suspension to to get into I guess a game
day flow what what are you if you can
work on anything to get ready for the
long term first season crucible that you
have in front of you coach yeah you know
last year was really day-to-day and when
I say that early meaning it was
day-to-day it was so much going on there
and then this is this year's been more
of an opportunity to really plan ahead
and forecast
you know the preseason and then as we
get into the first game so you know
that's been really good and there's a
lot of things you're ready for you're
prepared for and you know the prepare my
whole life is this opportunity but as I
also know there's gonna be things to
come up along the way that that we don't
foresee and so we have to be able to
adjust along the way and I think we've
built a really good chemistry with the
staff and with the players you know
during preseason camp you know one of
the mantras been toughness we we really
have to be tough I think if we are tough
and and we love each other then we're
gonna have a great year and so still a
journey it's it's not a finished product
by any stretch of the imagination but it
we're off to a good start here what have
you changed from what Urban Meyer had
put in there I mean just in terms of
your stamp what is the Ryan Day stamp
that that wasn't there before
yeah it's a question I get a lot you
know and people try to compare you know
they said what are you doing different
or how are you different or different
than our Meyer and you know thing I
always say first off is you don't
replace a legend you know and not trying
to do that I'm trying to figure out what
are the things that were built in the
program over the last seven years that
have been something
first off that I believe in that we'd
like to enhance and then some other
things you'd like to tweak along the way
and anytime you change something within
an organization it takes energy takes
time and so you know there's little
things here and there that we're
changing but for the most part we've
kept the infrastructure of the program
in place now there's a change on defense
so that's a whole other whole new staff
really there with new schematics on that
side you know we have you know a new
quarterback here so the personnel is
really different but at the same time
the core values the philosophies just
stay the same brian deo coach of Ohio
State football right here on the Rich
Eisen show let's talk about your
quarterback Justin Fields why did you
why did you go and and for lack of a
better phrase get Justin Fields why why
when he transferred out of Georgia did
you open your arms and welcome him when
you had somebody like Tate Martel in the
mix right yeah that was it was a very
unique situation and I think now more
than ever the quarterback position is a
very sensitive situation and so
especially the place I go hyoe state and
we were coming off the heels of one of
the best basketball foremen TSA's in the
history of the Big Ten and Dwayne you
know up in leaves for the for the NFL as
a sophomore which is unheard of you know
we weren't even sure if you could take a
snap going to last game first game last
year and then he throws 50 touchdowns
and so by him leaving that kind of upset
the applecart a little bit you know we
plan ahead in recruiting
there's a lot that goes into that and so
once he decided to declare Justin Fields
you know was available on the market and
you know we recruited him coming out of
high school and really thought very
highly of him and and then when he you
know showed interest in us yeah we
thought it was a slam dunk that way and
and then you know along with that there
was there was a lot of movement within
our room and we lost to eight and we
lost Matt it was hard because you know
guys want to play and and you know
sometimes they they forecast ahead and
sometimes accurately sometimes
inaccurately what they think is gonna
happen and Justin came in did a great
job worked hard and he's earned the
starting job here this preseason so
and obviously you know quarterbacks very
well you were one for Chip Kelly who
hired you twice as being a quarterback
coach in in the pros when when he was in
Philly and then you went with him to San
Francisco why why do you like Justin
fields so much Ryan well his skill set
is off the charts first off is big he's
63 generally around 230 he's got real
speed he's you know been clocked under a
four-four he's got a very strong arms
intelligent good leadership that hasn't
played a lot of football so you know
Dwayne had the opportunity to be in the
system here you know working on his
third year last year where Justin just
showed up in January so he doesn't have
the you know the benefit of being in the
program for a while so he's gonna he's
gonna be mistakes made but I think his
ceiling is very very high did you say
even think Duane Haskins would be taking
a snap before week one last year did I
hear that accurately my earpiece yeah I
said we weren't sure if he could
was it because of injury or something
like oh no just because he had never
done it I kind of remember one time
feeling kind of confident in a game in
the big house or JT Barrett got hurt and
I thought well here comes this kid no
big deal and he was a big deal
I don't I kind of remember that ya know
and he stepped up in a big way and
really you know that was one of the big
reasons why you know we gave the Wayne
the nudge you know or you know the the
nod over Joe Pearl because that spring
we had to decide who we thought was
going to be the starter in our future
and that was a very hard decision
because Joe burrows excellent
quarterback a lot of leadership had been
in the program I get broke his hand that
year and then they competed like crazy
during that spring and and we gave the
weigh-in the slight advantage going into
pre-season and then Joe decided to go to
LSU and you know Dewayne really hadn't
done a lot going into that year I mean
the week before he did that in the big
house he came out against Illinois in
the rain and fumbled unlike the second
play returned for a touchdown you know I
mean and so we just weren't sure but
then obviously as we got going during
the season
we realized that he was more than ready
to go well I'll tell you I think
Washington's got itself a winner that's
for darn sure I really like what I'm
seeing in the preseason obviously that
it's preseason and obviously he's gonna
make some mistakes but he's dropped some
serious times and I know I have spoken
to Coach Meyer I in terms of rating
Haskins
throwing the ball he put him at the very
top of anybody he's ever seen Ryan he's
office yeah he's off the charts in terms
of that you know I was lucky enough to
be around Matt Ryan when he was that age
and you know saying Bradford and some of
those guys in the NFL
I mean he's ahead of them just in terms
of raw talent but he just hasn't played
a lot of games and so every time he
steps on the field you're gonna see him
improve I think he saw that in the
preseason he just has an innate accuracy
he has a great vision and you know he's
big enough to see downfield and he's
really working his body too did a great
job when he was here and he's become
athletic enough to get himself out of
trouble so I'm with you I think I think
the Redskins they've got a gem they're
few more minutes left with Orion Day
Ohio State football head coach here on
the Rich Eisen show what in the world
was it like being a quarterback at New
Hampshire for Chip Kelly the backhander
seriesin walk me through what that was
like
it's cure so it was like a laboratory
every week so the first year was my
first year starting quarterback that was
his first year being a coordinator and
every week we change the offense so it
would go from the veer to the wing T to
run and shoot to you know anything
and we just change it on a weekly basis
and I can't tell you as the quarterback
I had a great GPA that semester most of
my time in the office with you but we
had a lot of fun we've grown a lot of
points and then and next year is when we
really bought into the no-huddle and
that was kind of the beginning of the
no-huddle where we were just trying to
run as many plays as possible that's all
I cared about you know can we get 120
plays this game and and we got ourselves
in shape and kind of got that going with
the Novato and years later he started
organ so pretty neat to be a part of and
so he he is obviously out there in UCLA
right now now you're you're at Ohio
State it's amazing just how paths take
place how did you get hooked up with
Ohio State though I mean I'm look
you're history here and your lineage how
did you wind up in Columbus
now you're the head coach of the entire
program after Urban Meyer leaves Ryan
yeah yeah so it kind of went like this
when I was at Boston College so Chip
Kelly and I and Dan Mullen are all from
the same hometown of Manchester New
Hampshire okay when I was at Boston
College we were gonna play in the Fiesta
Bowl against Utah we didn't make it
because we lost the last game to
Syracuse but I kind of called Dan Mullen
and said I'd love to get together and
meet you and because I didn't know him
at the time and me or Mayer well I think
a week later he gets the job at Florida
and I get a call from Dan Mullen do you
want to be the graduate assistant of
Florida so my wife and I get you all we
drive down the Florida and for a year in
2005 I was on the staff with Herbert and
Dan from then you know I worked with
Stephen a CEO who was on that staff at
Boston College always stayed very close
with her van just you know staying in
touch phone calls coming to visit and
then when I was out at the 49ers so with
chip I had an opportunity to come a
couple years ago and moved to Columbus
do you think he coaching's out of Urban
Meyer do you think he's it's it's it
he's done do you think he's done yeah I
don't know I mean I I know he's happy I
know that you know his family's happy
and he's got a big smile on his face and
you know he comes around you know once a
week um so who knows you know you don't
know those things but I know that he's
very very happy and I know it's not his
plans right now but but you just never
know from there but he is he is there
once a week he's around the program was
yeah yeah he'll stop by all the time and
he's always reference they'll call and
text and I'll call him with questions
and it's been an unbelievable resource
and he and Shelley have been great for
Nate and I all right before I let you go
let's get to the elephant in the room
right now coach ding okay let's get
right to it can you say that do you say
the word Michigan can you say the word
do say and no come on
so even if you take a trip there you say
what do you say like how do you refer to
the state come on I say I say the word
Ohio all the time it's easy well I mean
I mean you can do it but you know that
effect little push-ups I mean we
I'll just going to say the state up
north we'll stay in our room we'll say
the blue team maybe even say the
Wolverines but we certainly can't say
the M word me and if my creases say it
then they're really in trouble I did not
do what like laps around the house no I
have taught now look in full disclosure
I have taught my my kids that the two
teams we dislike the most is his Ohio
State and whoever's playing Ohio State I
mean I've full disclosure I have taught
them that do you not even use the letter
M do you exit out do you do that too now
you well I know why my daughter came to
practice yesterday and she had a stalker
shirt on and it was blue and she the
first thing she came over so dad I'm so
sorry I'm wearing a blue jersey blue
shirt right now but as my soccer jersey
I didn't have anything else to wear I
said honey it's okay we'll make sure
next time you don't have a blue shirt on
you know I'll just tell you this it's on
I mean I'm not talk about your parenting
I'm just talking about in general I
think it's unhealthy it's unhealthy well
people we're all people on the planet
Ryan you know I mean we're all big
tanners in a way I guess even though I
just said that I do root for anybody
that does play you I guess it's just
full disclosure here is that we are all
representing the Big Ten when it comes
down to it right yeah yes we are yes we
are I grew up in Boston whether it was
the Red Sox Yankees and that's like a
way of life too so I think I completely
understand what it means and and I enjoy
it okay it's I think it's fun have you
connected with LeBron yet you know I
haven't I had love to but I am NOT I
think that day's coming soon Ryan I mean
he's you know that they will be that day
will be kind he knows the whole thing
about not wearing blue and all that all
that business listen good luck to you
sir what an opportunity that you have
right there in front of you and I
appreciate you calling I hope this is
not the last time it's the first of many
now thank you very much respect for you
and the worst you do thank you for to be
back on soon all right you got it that's
Ryan day head coach of the Ohio State
for more of the Rich Eisen show tune -
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV for free
on Br
live or download the Rich Eisen show app